dans les entrailles de l'afrique du sud
quelque chose s'est réveillé
[Musique]
à l'abri de la lumière un mystérieux
fossiles attendaient d'être mis au jour
depuis 3,7 millions d'années une scène
de crime qui pourrait changer à jamais
l'histoire de l'évolution humaine
au coeur de la faire une victime hors du
commun
son nom little foot sexe féminin
taille 1 m 30 son espèce
australopithecus prometheus
particularité un squelette presque
complet pour identifier les
circonstances de sa mort trouver sa
place dans le grand arbre de notre
révolution
un paléo anthropologue et un
géomorphologie sts poursuivre une
enquête au coeur du berceau de
l'humanité
en analysant les eaux de lidl foot les
scientifiques ont pu décrire la
morphologie d'un australopithèque avec
une précision jamais atteinte et
découvert des indices sur le
fonctionnement de son cerveau un cerveau
bien différent du nôtre et qu'un scanner
microtomographie qu a permis de
modéliser
quels étaient les particularités
d'australopithecus prometheus
comment percevez t-il son environnement
et combien d'autres squelettes attendent
d'être découverts dans ces grottes
devenus de véritables pièges à fossiles
préparez vous pour une enquête au coeur
de nos origines
[Musique]